dieser ferienhausvermieter aus
clausthal-zellerfeld sorgte dafür dass
familien um doch ihren urlaub in
niedersachsen verbringen können der harz
rebell klagte erfolgreich vor dem
gericht in lüneburg und kippte das
beherbergungs verbot jetzt wird jens
lutz bei urlaubern und gastronomen als
held gefeiert
der ausbilder war die 180 grad wende der
niedersächsischen landesregierung das
beherbergungs verbot eben mit
einzuführen für hieß es noch wir führen
es nicht ein
unser ministerpräsident nun mit einmal
wurde es doch irgendwann das hin und her
in der landesregierung ist für den
tourismus gift die urlauber sind
verunsichert die gastronomen fürchten um
ihre existenz die einnahmen könnte ich
jetzt noch nicht beziffern beim selber
wird es so auf ende oktober ein etwa 10
bis 15 prozent im laufen
dadurch dass ich natürlich hätte oder
kreisvorsitzender bin habe ich viel
kontakt zu rütteln
wo es wesentlich dramatischen einbußen
von 30 40 prozent eben zu bezeichnen
sind
das beherbergungs verbot in
niedersachsen ist nun also vorerst vom
tisch
jetzt muss nur noch das wetter stimmen
damit die gäste im harz schöne ferien
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren